e
e e
the house will attend to a Prayer by
guest chaplain Reverend Reed ly Rector
of St Andrew's Episcopal Church in
hopkington
good morning
morning in My Religion we speak of the
communion of saints which by which we
mean the living relationship with those
who have gone before us where love
persists we pray not so much to the
Saints as with
them welcoming their character and Light
to embolden our
own recognizing the spiritual diversity
of this chamber I hope that in this
prayer with a recently departed Saint
you will find in the way in which you
understand the persistent Echoes of love
some accompaniment today in bearing your
light
forward let us pray
God in whom our many lives Find Unity in
whom a living relationship is known with
all who have gone before and with those
at any distance who share the pursuit of
love and truth I thank you today for the
life of Jimmy Carter who was satisfied
to lead from his values to make those
values plain for other others and to
have his values challenged and sharpened
by those around
him May those of every political
conviction in the legislature of this
state be strengthened to their own best
efforts by the remembrance of Jimmy
Carter's neighbor love his actual
preference for righteousness over
reelection and his bodily defining of
Integrity in public office
in Jimmy Carter we remember that our
pluralism reveals more
truth and that the light of leadership
is in speech and law but also in Daily
kindness help this body in the
remembrance of this saint and of all
those who have exemplified the work of
the political life amen
the chair recognizes the member of
Manchester representive Patricia Cornell
who will lead us in the pledge of
allegiance of the United States of
America and to
the stands na God indivisible withy and
justice for all
the chair recognizes the paragram
quartet from northern voices a capetta
who will sing our national anthem
[Music]
so
the of the
free and
the of
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for
leaves of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives ball papichi Mueller
Snodgrass Spain valno Woods the day
important business Representatives
Crawford DD pulin and
levit these leades of absent shall be
Grant a setwise order by the house the
house will attend to the
in introduction of guests Mr Speaker
please welcome Lin Sanford homeschooler
from gtown and Adele debowski
homeschooler from New Boston are Pages
for the
day welcome to the new hampture house
Mr
Speaker please welcome Steve and Cole
April guests of Representative Doug
Thomas Kimberly PLJ and Carrie September
daughter and guest of Representative PLJ
Kendra debowski guest of Representative
aan Barbara Salvatore and Don mson
guests of Representative priest Lori
melier wife of Representative melier and
Sebastian Fuentes guest of
Representative Baldwin they are with us
in the gallery today
[Applause]
the house will attend to a
communication Mr Speaker in a letter
dated December 18 2024 dear Paul please
be advised that the following
Representatives elect were sworn into
office by the governor and Council on
this day hillsbor County District 3 PA
Bosman bellnap County District 2 Matthew
Coker Hillsboro County District 45 Jack
Flanigan chesher County District 1 Dylan
ger Hillsboro County District 31 Molly
Howard Hillsboro County District 23 uh
Jean Judy Hillsboro County District
number 32 Jim kofalt Hillsboro County
District number one Sandra panck
Hillsboro County District Number 8 Kevin
Scully Carrol County District 8 Brian
Taylor sincerely David M scanland
Secretary of
State W Welcome to the New Hampshire
houseing congratulations
right oh
okay the H will come to order I will now
administer the oath of office to the
sergeant of arms
Raise Your
Right raise your right hand and we're
appropriate state your name and town I
JB
cullin do solemnly swear do solemnly
swear that I will bear faith that I will
give faith and true Allegiance and true
allegiance to the United States of
America to the United States of America
and to the state of New Hampshire and to
the state of New Hampshire and will
support the Constitutions thereof so
help me God and will support the
Constitution of God so help me God I I
JB Colin do solemnly and sincerely swear
to solemnly and sincerely swear and
affirm that I will faithfully and affirm
that I will faithfully and impartially
discharge and my impartially discharge
Legion guide and perform all the duties
and perform all the duties incumbent
upon me incumbent upon me as as Sergeant
at Arms of the House of Representatives
of the House of Representatives
according to the best of my abilities
according to the best of my ability
agreeable to the rules agreeable to the
rules and regulations of and the
regulations of the Constitution and laws
of the State of New Hampshire the
Constitution and the laws of the State
of New Hampshire so help me God so help
me God congratulations thank you sir
[Applause]
[Music]
the house will attend to a resolution Mr
Speaker Representatives Osborne and
Simpson offer the following resolved
that the House of Representatives inform
the honorable Senate it is ready to meet
in joint convention for the purpose of
canvasing the votes for governor and
executive counsel are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I I
suppos nay the eyes have the resolution
is
adopted
e e
recognize the clerk for a senate message
house will come to order Mr Speaker the
Senate is ready to meet with the House
of Representatives in joint convention
for the purpose of canvasing the votes
for governor and executive councel
representative
Raymond representative Raymond
recogniz Sergeant the house will come to
order the chair recognizes a Sergeant at
Arms Mr Speaker The Honorable Senate
[Applause]
J recognizes the Sergeant at
Arms Mr Speaker president of the Senate
The Honorable Sharon Carson of
londonairy
[Applause]
[Music]
The Joint convention will come to order
the joint convention has been formed for
the purpose of canvasing vote the votes
for governor and executive councel
The Joint convention will attend to a
resolution Mr Speaker Representatives
Osborne and Senator buril offer the
following resolved that The Honorable
Secretary of State be requested to lay
before the joint convention the return
votes for governor and executive councel
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay the
eyes have it and the resolution is
adopted the chair recognizes a serent at
Arms
Mr Speaker New Hampshire's Secretary of
State The Honorable David M scanland
[Applause]
The Joint convention will attend to a
resolution okay recogn
secetary J recognizes the Secretary of
State thank you Mr Speaker Madame
President and members of the general
court uh as required by part two
articles 42 and 60 of the New Hampshire
Constitution
I appear before you on this day the
first Wednesday after the first Tuesday
in January of
2025 to present the return of votes for
governor and executive counsel that were
cast in the general election held on
November 5th
2024 for governor in belnap County Kelly
aot received
24732 votes Joyce Craig received
14762 votes and Steven villy received
718 votes in Carroll County aot received
19,1 4 Craig received
14,407 Philly received
626 in chesher County aot received 21,
342 votes Craig received
22,170
and3 Coos County aot received
10,47 Craig receiv received receiv
received
6,349 Philly received
439 Grafton County aot
24260 Craig
29,200 Philly
1,236
Hillsboro County
125,1 183 votes for
aat Craig received
10,395 villy received 4,
477 in marac County aot received
47,7
192 Craig received
4270 Philly received
1,795 in Rockingham County aot received
113,877
Craig received
82344 and Billy received
3,575 votes
excuse me in straford County aart
received 36,40 votes Craig received
37,6 41 Philly received
1,66 in Sullivan County aot received
13,25 Craig received
10,862 and Billy received
667 so the overall totals were Kelly kot
received
436,000
149 votes and Steven villy received
16,22
votes so Kelly aot having a plurality of
75,76 votes uh was elected governor
[Applause]
[Music]
for executive councel in the first
district Joseph Kenny received
87,134 votes EMT selati received
7,647 votes and having a plurality of
16,48 votes Joseph Kenny was elected
counselor in the second district Karen
Le oill received 87,3
votes Kim strathy received
66,1 15 votes having a plurality of
2,483 votes Leo Hill Leo Hill was
elected counselor in the Third District
Janet Stevens received
92,3 4 votes John Morgan received
75,500 votes
Janet Stevens was elected
counselor in the fourth district John
Steven received 77,000 193 votes Jim
oconnell received
66,800 to votes having a plurality of
11,061 votes John Steven was elected
counselor in the Fifth District Dave
wheer received 81,500
vake received 71,9 3 votes having a
plurality of
10,561 votes David wheeler was elected
counselor so Mr Speaker that concludes
my report and I would like to wish all
the members of both Chambers a very
productive and successful session thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
The Joint convention will attend to a
resolution Mr Speaker representative
Osborne and Senator BS will offer the
following resolve that the vote for a
governor and councel be referred to a
committee consisting of three on the
part of the house and two on the part of
the Senate to compare and count the same
and Report there on on the part of the
House Representative Steven Smith ducet
and Simpson on part of the Senate
Senators bsel and Perkins
quoka are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those nay the
guys have't the resolution is
adopted representative Osborne and
Senator bursill move that the joint
convention arise are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the joint convention is adjourned
a
the house will come to
order the house will attend to the
introduction of bills Mr Speaker
representative Osborne offers the
fallowing resolved that in accordance
with the list in the possession of the
clerk house bills number 1050 through
381 house concurrent resolutions
numbered 1-5 house joint resolution 1
house resolutions 6 through 11 and
Constitutional Amendment concurrent
resolutions 1-5 shall be by this
resolution read a first and second time
by the therein listed titles and
referred to the therein designated
committees are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay eyes have it the
resolution is
adopted representative osbor and Simpson
move the adoption of an amendment to
house rule 66 as proposed by the rules
committee and printed in the house
calendar are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it amendment is
adopted represent Osborne moves the
adoption of an amendment to house rule
28 as proposed by the rules committee
and is printed in the house
calendar
chair chair recognize representative
Penza
chair recognizes representative
deler thank you Mr Speaker good morning
everyone I'll be
brief um this change to subpoena power
this proposed change first I believe
it's unne necessary the reality is under
current rules issuing a subpoena in this
house is a practical
impossibility what this rule change does
is it adds so many different steps and
so many different hands that it has to
go through it codifies a practical
impossibility into an actual
impossibility and then it does one more
thing we have a duty to preserve
zealously the powers of this body the
Constitution gives this body the power
of inherent contempt we have the
authority though we won't use it anytime
soon I'm sure to take a vote hold
someone in contempt and enforce it
ourselves this rule would give that
authority over to the executive branch
by causing them to take up a
contempt and possibly not pursue it that
pres that power needs to be preserved
here thank
you chair recognize representative Weber
thank you Mr
Speaker as was noted the house already
has the power to issue a subpoena we
don't need a rule change to be able to
do
[Music]
that the change that's before us adds in
a procedure for when a committee wants a
um subpoena to issue they can already
come to the Full House we don't need a
rule for them to do
that but what this would require is it
adds in a trip to the rules committee
before the matter goes to the Full
House and the thing that is the most
difficult for me is that it adds the
speaker enforcement
powers and when we were in the rules
committee we were told that there would
be a follow-up
bill that would elaborate at on the
speaker's enforcement
Powers I don't know what's in that bill
that bill as a bill would come to us
here in the house and we would vote on
it that's fine guess where it goes next
it goes to another chamber who may
change it into something we don't like
and then it has to be signed by the
governor so we don't know what powers we
are
giving I don't sign a contract without
reading it I don't
vote on rules or bills that have not
been properly vetted and I hope you will
join me in voting against this one by
pressing the red
button chair recognizes representative
when
thank you Mr Speaker u i rise in support
of the proposed uh Amendment to the
rules I think it's important to State at
the beginning that I don't disagree with
the assertion that the house has the
inherent authority to issue subpoenas
the problem is that the current the
current rule is really very vague about
the circumstances under which that can
happen when it should happen that kind
of thing and that resulted frankly in a
very unfortunate
situation uh U last term that's what
this amendment is designed uh to uh to
change and it's
true that the purpose of this amendment
is to is to sort of limit the authority
of when subpoenas are issued and to make
sure that in fact when subpoenas are
issued
the leadership of the house knows about
it is on board with it through the rules
committee and that the speaker is also
on board with it um that's what this
does it provides a process for the
issuance of
subpoenas and which I assume as
everybody has said and I completely
agree with would be relatively a very
rare situation um as you know I've been
in the house for this was my third term
I know there are people who have been
here a lot longer than I have who have
said that putting aside the the uh the
situation involving the the impeachment
of uh former Chief Justice Brock in 2000
they can't remember a time when
subpoenas were ever issu when when
subpoenas were ever issued so this
idea of issuing subpoenas to compel
testimony or to compel the production of
documents is is really a very rare thing
and if we're you know if we're going to
I think the IDE the whole idea of this
rule is if we're going to start down
that road of doing it let's proceed with
a great deal of caution let's make sure
that before that happens the house is on
the house leadership is on board with
that and the speaker is on board with
that I'm a committee chair I don't want
the the power to have to be able to
issue a subpoena on my own and I don't
want my committee to have the the power
to issue a subpoena on its own because
that might mean my committee will have
one standard another committee will have
another standard that shouldn't be the
way we we we sort of start on a new
process it may be a rare process but
it's it's one that's pretty important
and it's one that can end up in in the
end with um with with some pretty
significant consequences it's
correct that the speaker
could if this if the rule were complied
with the speaker presumably could order
the sergeant in-arms to go out and
arrest someone that had not complied
with a
subpoena that hasn't that has never
happened as far as I'm aware in New
Hampshire I think it's probably happened
pretty rarely around the country from a
little bit of research I I did my
understanding is that the Congress of
the United States last did something
like that over a hundred years ago in
1914 so it's a pretty rare
situation um it seems to me we want to
make sure that it's it's a very
controlled situation so that's why I
think this this proposed amendment makes
sense thank you does the member yielder
question I do remember
yields thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you for taking my question I just wanted
to clarify something if this rule right
now is voted down will committee chairs
and committies have the authority to
issue a
subpoena that's an excellent question
and I think the answer is we're not
really sure about that as as evidenced
by as evidenced by what happened last
term somebody some committee chair
apparently thought that they did have
that Authority um so uh you know
that's the whole point I think this is
designed to clarify
that the motion before us is the
adoption of amendment to house rule
28 are youis a division has been recall
has been called members take your seats
stations are on would everybody make
sure your voting stations are turned on
the motion before us is the adoption of
to amend of the amendment to house rule
28 this is a division vote chair
recognize representative Weber for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker despite what you have
just heard if I know that whether we
adopt this amendment
or whether we leave the rules as they
are they are both crystal clear that no
subpoena shall issue except by majority
vote of the entire house membership and
on the signature of the
speaker and if I further know that I do
not want to get involved in adopting a
lengthy procedure part of which we do
not know yet and over which we may not
have full control would I now press the
red button to defeat this amendment
thank
you chair recognize representative Lynn
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the process
under the current rule which is very
minimal in terms of its wording um is is
confusing and has as evidenced by what
happened last term and if if I know that
this Pro process puts some meat on the
rule to make it to make it
um understandable to to the members of
the house and also to ensure that no
subpoenas are issued unless there is uh
Buy in by the leadership and by the
speaker then would I press the green
button to support this
amendment the motion before us is the
adoption of amendment to house rule 28
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
if all members present under opportunity
to vote house will attend to the state
of the
vote 150 voting a 229 voting a the
amendment fails
represented Osborne moves adoption of an
amendment to house rule 2 as proposed by
the rules committee and is printed in
the house
calendar J recognizes representative
n thank you Mr Speaker I move to table
the house rule that is printed in the
calendar on page
three the motion is to table the
adoption of amendment to house rule two
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay the
eyes have it and the motion is laid on
the
table representative osbor and Simpson
moved the adoption of an amendment to
house rule 43 as proposed by the rules
commit and has printed in the house
calendar are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the amendment
is
adopted representative obor Osborne
moves the adoption of an amendment to
house rule 44 as proposed by as proposed
by the rules committee and as printed in
the house calendar
G recognize your representative Osborne
for a
motion thank you Mr Speaker I move to uh
lay this amendment about tabling on the
table the motion is to move to lay on
the table amendment to house rule 44 are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I those oppose nay the eyes
have it the amendment is laid on the
table the house will be in
order we will now attend to a floor
[Music]
amendments representative n moves an
amendment to house rule
two and it is in your seat
pocket when the house is in session all
members of the House chamber shall be
dressed in a proper business attire not
need to
okay chair recognizes representative
Prout thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to
speak against this
amendment the only way to enforce this
would essentially be to make a motion to
reprimand a member and we tried that in
this body five years ago I was the the
subject of an attempt to do that
I don't think it went well for anyone
involved um and I suggest that we do not
adopt this and do not start down that
path again where the only practical way
to do anything in in regards this of
someone violating it is to go down that
road again which is not a good road and
also this rule is vague I mean proper
business attire can mean different
things to different people I mean I'm
wearing jeans today with a suit jacket
and quite frankly this is more formal
than I usually dress when I present at
conferences in front of hundreds of
people
um so it's going to mean different
things to different people it's just
it's going to take us down a morass that
we don't want to spend our time talking
about again and again please vote no
thank
you chair recognizes Brian
Sullivan thank you Mr
Speaker I Rise also in opposition to
this uh Amendment um for some of the
same reasons the prior um speaker
mentioned um proper business attire is
not defined in statute or in
rules so where do you find a
definition Google of
course so I Googled
it and what I found was that proper
business attire is not being followed by
a large number of the members in this
chamber today
including
me um I'm not wearing dress
shoes and I don't wear dress shoes
because I've got a big knot on my right
big
toe more information than you needed um
I'm also not wearing proper dress slacks
I think they look okay my wife even said
I look nice as I left this morning so I
I'll take it from my wife that I'm doing
all
right but the bottom line is if this was
enforced and taken very seriously by a
future
speaker
um we would have a hard time dealing
with all of the folks who would be in
violation um I think it's a bad
idea let me say what's a good idea
though it's a good idea for all of us to
be respectful of the body respectful of
the constituent who sent us here and
respectful of
ourselves we should be dressing
appropriately that's not well defined
either but I think most of us know it
when we see
it and if someone defines appropriately
inappropriately then perhaps the
leadership from their caucus ought to
have a chat with them
if it's a woman who's dressing
inappropriately I would suggest that a
woman member of leadership chat with her
um I certainly don't want to be the one
doing it um we're going to have sexual
harassment TR training later today um I
think this opens a slippery slope for uh
many of us so bottom line is Google says
we're all all out of line not all of us
many of us are out of line um let's use
our heads let's dress appropriately
let's be respectful of this institution
and let's vote red on this please thank
you J recognized representative
not thank you Mr
Speaker Representatives Hall
Representatives Hall is a hallowed
institution with over 200 years of
history the history of dignity and
respect and the way we dress should
reflect
that now the previous speaker spoke of
having leadership talk to the members if
they're dressed inappropriately well we
can't because there's no rule how many
times we've heard people say why is that
person dressed that way why are they
wearing the T-shirt ripped jeans casual
clothes sport know
and uh well we can't talk to them
because there's no
rule so when I first learned about
politics in New Hampshire it was 2008
and one of my mentors was then speaker
well former speaker Donna scitec and we
talked about how to dress in the house
and she told me she always wore a jacket
and my first term I had a friend who
couldn't afford to go to the department
store and buy fancy clothes she went to
Goodwill she had two jackets and she
switched them out and then her second
term she had a third jacket to add to
the
rotation so this isn't
about calling a fashion police together
and and look at and see I always look to
see what shoes um being worn in the
first Roka she has best shoes in the
house but no one's looking at your shoes
I don't think anybody's going to notice
your pants the public sees us from the
waist up we're elected officials and we
should be dressed appropriately
especially in represent
Hall so I ask you to support the
amendment and press the green button
thank
you the motion before us is to the adopt
floor amendment to house rule two are
you ready for the question Division
division has been called members take
your seats
clear
the motion before us is the floor
amendment to house rule two this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
all MERS presid had an opportunity to
vote house will attend to stay to the
vote
183 voting a 196 voting a the amendment
fails representative Sweeney moves
amendment to floor amendment to house
rule
44b chair recognizes representative
Wilhelm it is in your seat pockets
thank you Mr Speaker so on convening day
two years ago we gathered here in this
chamber and passed a number of
amendments that the rules committee
recommended on a bipartisan basis one of
those amendments which I was proud to
co-sponsor with the majority leader my
good friend from
Auburn which added language to house
rule 44 that is Up For Debate today
the rules committee recommended that
language on Executive session notice two
years ago because it would improve our
process it would assure that the public
is properly notified of our business and
that decisions to enter executive
session on the same day as the Bill's
public hearing would be made with
thoughtful
consensus the amendment passed on a
Voice vote and for the past two years
rule 44 has worked
well obviously this is a new term
committee membership is no longer tied
and with a two- seat majority on every
committee Republicans will be able to
report bills out with any desired
recommendation on a Partyline
vote our public notice standards need
not be rolled back for the majority to
accomplish its objectives of course
chairs need to have tools at their
disposal to move bills along and meet
our deadlines the existing rule
appropriately provides those
tools if a committee wants to enter
executive session after a Bill's public
hearing to honor a family in attendance
or dispose of legislation that the
committee unanimously agrees needs no
further work the rule as it currently
stands permits
that I've yet to hear of a scenario
where the current rule impedes a
committee from entering executive
session for good
reason house rule 44 as currently
written and adopted works well for
committees and provides appropriate
notice to the public I urge members to
vote no on the pending motion to retain
the existing rule on Executive session
notice thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize represent
Sweeny thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
two years ago this house passed on a
bipartisan basis a rule change
reflective of the makeup of the house at
the time in order to Ure a fair process
uh for all bills coming forward in the
last few weeks I have heard a lot from
constituents my colleagues here in this
house many of you about traditions and
honoring time honor traditions of the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
now is the time as we embark on a new
two-year session to review the rules
changes that we made two years ago to
accommodate the the situation of the
house breakdown at the time and see how
we can get back to some of those older
time honored Traditions uh that we
hastily abandoned those two years ago uh
to restore these New Traditions uh old
traditions back into the house for the
future uh two years terms and
potentially even longer beyond that uh
which is why I brought forward this
amendment to house rule 44b uh so that
we can go back to the Traditions that we
used to cherish as this body uh to
ensure that committees and the chairman
have the tools at their disposal uh to
act on the people's behalf as we
consider all of the issues that are
going forward in New Hampshire uh as
they they hear bills and their
committees or as issues come up that
committee chairman and their committees
can work together in order to move the
process forward and deliver Real Results
for the people of New Hampshire that is
the spirit of this rule Amendment and I
hope you will agree with me and vote
green to restore a time honored house
tradition and let's get back to the
people's work thank you is the member
yeldo a question I do not member does
not
yield the motion before us is floor
amendment to house rule 44 are you ready
for the question a division has been
called members take your seats
the motion before us is floor amendment
to house rule 44b this is a division
vote chair recognize representative
Weber for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I
remember a time when under a similar
rule chairs despite the requirement in
our rules that executive sessions get
enough notice so the public can be here
to watch them if they want
to chairs used to post in the calendar a
statement along the line of
executive sessions may be heard at any
time time
permitting and if I think it is
deplorable that we would not give a Time
certain for the public to come and watch
us do their work would I now vote no on
this proposed rule change by pressing
the red button thank you Mr Speaker
chair as representative s Sweeney for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this rule had
been in place for decades before we took
it away two years ago Mr Speaker if I
know that this rule was in place in
Republican and Democrat administrations
of this house majority and Mr Speaker if
I know that we can trust our committee
chairman and the members of the
committee to act on the Public's behalf
in full light would I now press the
green button to pass this rule Amendment
what reason does a member
rise I Rise to a matter of privilege Mr
Speaker called
us this rule has never what what is your
privilege this rule has never been in
effect under a Democratic
Leadership we were always required to
notice at a time certain always
did the did the member from salum
finish I I would just say I disagree
with that interpretation no no that's
that's that's not it sorry would I now
press the green button the motion before
us is amendment to house rule 44b this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
representative
Edwards all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to stay to the vote what's the
matter you didn't tell me you were here
representative how would you like to
vote
please you didn't check in when you
arrived sorry thank you
I'll ask again if all members present
had an opportunity to vote house will
attend to stay to the
vote 199 voting yay 181 voting nay the
amendment is adopted
representative Osborne moves floor
amendment to house Rule
46c and has recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker uh so those
of us who have been here for the past
two years and I guess even those of us
who haven't have probably heard Legend
of Representative
postpone um because we did not have this
rule in place that I'm proposing again
today um we had to resort to uh not
ideal motions in order to expedite the
uh uh business of the house uh in
particular when a committee has no
recommendation uh that they report uh to
this body um the default motion as it
stands today is ought to pass if ought
to pass is not going to be the eventual
uh prevailing motion it requires a
number of votes to get to the eventual
uh itl motion uh to be accepted by the
body
and U you know what it would be a whole
lot easier if the chairman could just
get up and make the itl motion to begin
with I think we all had enough
experience seeing that go the other way
and the problems that that caused uh
let's make our lives easier uh by uh
putting this rule in place thank you
very
much the motion before us is floor
amendment to house rule 46
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted representative McFarland offers
an amendment to house rule 64
and is
recognized representative ner chair
recognizes representative
ner thank you Mr Speaker the rule change
to house 64 presents some simple
clerical fixes to the rule it makes sure
that the security Personnel mentioned in
the rule are identified correctly as
they are properly mentioned in rule 62
and not rule
61 the amendment is in keep with house
tradition about display of self-defense
tools the house has limited the display
of firearms for years and this change
would be keeping with that tradition be
it Tartan day or someone standing at the
well where the slit in the jacket pops
open at the wrong time the goal of the
policy was always to prevent intentional
display of a firearm on the house
floor sitting in the front row I have
had to speak to a number of gentlemen
when their jacket hiked up when they
leaned over to speak into the microphone
and suddenly they were in unintentional
violation of a house rule the simple
change corrects that issue by clarifying
that the issue at hand is intentional
display versus inadvertent display I
would ask that you support this simple
change thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
mes
thank you Mr
Speaker this change would add the word
intentionally to the rule prohibiting
the display of deadly weapons in rep's
Hall I urge you to vote against this
motion because adding this one word
would unfortunately become a license to
become careless with the carrying of a
deadly
weapon carrying a concealed weapon
especially in this chamber means bearing
the responsibility to ensure that it
remains concealed and out of sight while
I know that many of my colleagues for
better of or Worse um do carry uh
Firearms into this chamber I can
honestly say that perhaps because of the
location I sit in in reps Hall I've
never personally seen a weapon uh
displayed either intentionally or
unintentionally here but one of the
reasons for that is that our current
rule doesn't have words like
intentionally or knowingly in it so the
bottom line is this if the display of a
weapon can be regarded as acceptable as
long as it's an accident we no longer
have an enforcable rule what we have is
the illusion of a
rule this isn't a matter of Freedom it's
a matter of self-discipline and personal
responsibility I urge you to vote no on
this amendment thank you
the motion before us is the floor
amendment to house rule 64 a roll call
has been requested is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote
the motion before is floor amendment to
house rule 64 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes the representative n
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that our house rules should not be set
up for inadvertently breaking them and
if I know that we should make sure that
we fix clerical issues that are
currently in the house rules would I now
press the green button on a to pass
motion thank you the motion before us
it's floor amendment to house R 64 this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if your
opposer press a red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 216 voting a 164 voting a the the
amendment is adopted
representative grer moves floor
amendment to house rule 20 again house
rule 20 chair recognizes representative
Rong thank you Mr Speaker this is a
simple rule with a simple represent
Granger R rung
thank you Mr Speaker there is a reason
why we require 3 fifths vote to special
order a bill and that's because these
bills are very special it could be a
widow of a law enforcement officer who's
died who's been killed on on the job and
who's here to watch a bill to
memorialize her husband it could be the
parents of a child who was killed by a
drunk driver who are here to w witness a
bill that would provide stricter
regulation on the serving of alcohol
we've seen these bills come and they're
always unanimous because they reflect
our humanity and our coming together in
a nonpartisan way to support Granite
Staters who are extremely invested in
the work that we do let's not change
that and make it a simple majority
because that will create Havoc we will
see special order motions coming and
going looking for that one vote margin
that majority in order to disrupt the
calendar and the public notice we've
given to our constituents to say hey
this is the order of the bills that
we're going to take up to remove that
ability to stick to our public notice in
our calendar is going to be create
confusion Havoc if it does not help us
fulfill our duty to Granite
Staters so I ask that you vote no on
this amendment let's keep special order
bills for those special bills that
people look to us for thank you chair
now the chair recognized representative
gr thank you Mr Speaker this is a return
to tradition uh we done this this way
for a very very long time uh his has
never been controversial a special order
motion is not the final motion on a bill
it just simply moves when you do it and
out of courtesy we should make it easier
for us to change which order we go
through bills to make it easier to
address the business of the day in an
effective efficient manner I urge you to
vote green thank
you the motion before floor amendment to
house rule
20 are you ready for the question a
division has been requested members take
your seats
I
see mhm
the motion before us is amend floor
amendment to house rule 20 this is a
division vote chair recognized
representative rung for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that requiring three fifths
requirement to special order a bill has
worked fine for those in frequent times
when a member of the public is here to
witness a vote on a bill inspired by
them or their family member like the
naming of a state road and if I also
know that straying from the Three-Fifths
requirement would invite chaos as any
member only needs a simple majority to
disrupt the scheduled order of noticed
bills as printed in the house calendar
and finally if I also know that we are
here to serve the public to serve the
people of New Hampshire not our own
convenience would I now press the red
button to continue our practice of
keeping special orders special thank you
chair recognized represent proud for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that what this rule change would do
is return us back to the tradition of
the way we did it before the most recent
term we did not see and if we if I know
we did not see all the problems that
have been stated by the other side of
this debate in terms of them being made
for trivial reasons them being made for
partisan reasons that just didn't happen
and if I know we did it last term
because of the unprecedented closeness
of the house that we don't have a again
this term would I press the green button
to return us to the process that worked
well for many years and allow us to
special order bills instead of a more
complicated series of other motions that
all require 50% but accomplish the same
thing thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is floor
amendment to house rule 20 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your oppos to
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds for
represent
MC represent
Murphy all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 21 voting a 117 voting a the
amendment is adopted
representative
Prout offers floor amendment to house
rule
39 and it's house rule
39e chair recognizes representative
proud
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker what
this rule change would do is allow
members to Prime sponsors of bills to
withdraw the bill later in the process
than they currently can is essentially
what it is and they need the concurrence
of all the house co-sponsors on the bill
to do that and so what how would work is
that if for whatever reason they find
out there's many bills on the same topic
they have a conversation with the
chairman whatever reason the prime
sponsor is convinced the right thing to
do is with withdraw the bill they can
notify the clerk get all the co-sponsors
also notify the clerk and then the the
committee chairman doesn't have to
schedule a public hearing and that
motion to withdraw it would go on the
consent calendar for us to vote on next
time we're in session now then there's
I've heard from some people and there's
some concerns could this be used to gain
the system in any way um and it's
written so that hopefully it can't be
and what I mean by that is is the
chairman of the committee doesn't have
to schedule a public hearing doesn't
have to exec the bill but it doesn't
prohibit them from doing that so if say
me a prime sponsor Bill heard the
committee was planning to amend a bill
with a non-gain Amendment or perhaps
even a Jimmy amendment in a way they
don't like and they want to withdraw the
bill to prevent that the committee can
just ignore the withdrawal request yes
we'd have we'd have to get the people to
pull it off consent and vote it down on
the floor if the committee is all in
favor of doing that I don't see that
being a major hurdle and that might
happen once and then people will realize
it doesn't work um so hopefully this is
a an efficient way
that people can't gain for partisan
reasons to get bills out of the process
once the prime sponsor admits this isn't
worth anyone's time thank you and please
vote
yay the motion before us is floor
amendment to house rule 39 are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it the motion the
amendment is adopted
representative Penza moves floor
amendment to house rule
36e
36e the chair recognizes representative
Penza
thank you Mr Speaker I'm G to keep it
easy so I know we all um make tons of
money in here so uh we have lots of time
on our hands and I just think that this
simple sentence um in our second term
when we're filing bills you can file one
bill on your own and then the rest you
have to have six sponsors since we have
to have 201 votes to pass a bill I think
this shows viability of your bill um to
be able to get six co-sponsors I don't
think that's much to ask and
um and that's pretty much it that's why
I put this
in a division has been called members
take your
seats e
the motion before us is an amendment to
house rule 6
36e this is a division vote the chair
recognizes repres presentive tki for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
proposed amendment would limit every one
of us to filing one bill in the second
year unless we find six co-sponsors to
sign on and if I know that we just went
through a challenging filing period with
tight deadlines late drafts calls to OSS
and for many of us we didn't have the
time or bandwidth to finalize our
co-sponsors when we were simply trying
to get our bill filed and over the
Finish Line never mind worry about
arbitrary requirements for co-sponsors
and finally if I know that each one of
us was chosen by our constituents to
participate in the legislative process
on their behalf which includes the
ability to file legislation for them and
this proposed amendment prevents us from
fulfilling our duties would I now press
the red button to stop this proposed
rule change thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative Penza for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that in the second year we have a lot
more time with Bill filing and if I know
that if I have a viable bill I can't get
six members to sign on then maybe I
shouldn't be fining that bill please
press the green button thank you the
motion before us is an amendment to
house rule 36e this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppose you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 83 voting a 295 voting a the
amendment
fails representative Penza moves floor
amendment to house rule 28 house rule
28 the chair recognizes Representative
Steven Smith
thank you Mr
Speaker well then this would make the
clerk of the house a very powerful
figure indeed more so than he is
now this rule would let committee chairs
issue subpoenas the committee chair
shall confer with the clerk of the house
on the substance of the subpoena and who
shall prepare the subpoena and issue it
so I guess if I'm having trouble getting
something from the Department of Safety
I would go talk to Paul Paul will figure
out how to write it up I don't know if
he's going to get counsel or not I'm
shocked that this rule doesn't say that
you confer with house counsel and then
when that's all done um it says issue it
so he's going to drive out to
commissioner Quinn's house and serve
him I am not sure that's how any of this
is supposed to
work who is the person who will defend
any incoming lawsuits or challenges the
clerk of the house has to get a lawyer
the reason the Speaker of the House does
it because we have house counsel and the
speaker is the
client house counsel also knows about
some of these things and can issue the
proper form so it's um not a great idea
but even if you think it is it's poorly
thought out and can't possibly work so
please vote against the amendment do you
recognize representa
Penza thank you Mr
Speaker currently if everybody reads the
current rule in place which is going to
stay in place if we don't make a
change all all all I'm changing is the
entire house
membership goes to committee the entire
committee votes on a subpoena
and then the committee chair works that
out specifically
with the clerk to write up a
subpoena there's nothing else in there
the other one was very complicated had a
lot of different parts and pieces to
it I really don't understand why our
rule currently does not align with the
subpena process that many states and
Congress is already consistent with if
it's 100% with Mason's Manual of
legislative procedure that is our book
that we should be looking to and
committees are closest to the subject
matter and the issues at
hand I there's been a lot of talk about
this today and I just don't understand
we're all talking about you know going
after people or anything like that it's
not about that I want to be able to as a
committee if we're looking for
information and we're getting a
roadblock I want to be able to get that
information whether whatever it may be
whatever committee you're in let's say
it's from an agency that's not
responding it would be really great to
be able to get them a certified letter
from the house from a committee to say
Hey you have to provide us that
information that's as simple it is I
don't have any other things in here I
keep it very clean I keep it simple this
proposal really is a step towards more
effective governance by simplifying the
process and ensuring equal power among
all committees this amendment ensures
that subpoena power is not vested in one
person and reduces legislators need to
jump through unattainable
hoops please vote
green the motion before us is floor
amendment to house rule
28 are you ready for the question all
those a division has been called members
take your seats
the motion before us is floor amendment
to house rule 28 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds e
[Music]
represent
D you got to give me a thumbs up or down
thank
you
Nat represent
V all members president had an
opportunity to vote house attendance
stay the
vote 83 voting a 299 voting a the
amendment
failed represa Muse offers floor
amendment to house rule 64o 64 the chair
recognizes representative Roy
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker this rule proposes to
bring us back to where we were a few
years ago um making members have to hide
their firearms and disobey rules because
I know that no one here is voluntarily
going to give up their constitutional
right we ask a lot of the members here
we we work a lot for a 100 bucks and we
take our safety seriously which is why a
lot of Us
carry every morning before I come here I
contemplate the danger that I'm going to
face and that a lot of children are
going to face and I'm not talking about
here I'm talking about on the road to
get here because that's where more
people die than worrying about children
being exposed to
Firearms everyone here is responsible
lawful gun owner if we're going to take
this right away from us what's next
we're not going to be able to speak
anymore because it might hurt somebody's
feelings we should have every right that
every other citizen does because we
should be an example to the freedoms of
the people in New Hampshire I would ask
you to oppose this rule thank
you chair recognized representative mes
thank you Mr
Speaker the amendment before us today
would restore a house rule that until
2011 had stood for over 40 years so if
we're talking about going back to
traditions of the New Hampshire house
this is actually a good way to do it if
we approve this amendment carrying or
possessing deadly weapons in this
chamber the gallery or our anti rooms
would once again be
prohibited New Hampshire is currently in
the minority of legislative B IES across
the country that allow deadly weapons to
be brought into the chamber while
displaying them is prohibited under our
current rules concealing them and
bringing them onto the floor is
allowed those who favor the current role
argue that banning guns from the chamber
would make us all soft targets for
terrorists and mass Shooters my reply to
that is the same as it was in 2023 when
I introduced a similar Amendment welcome
to the club with more firearms in
circulation than ever before it's become
sadly apparent that more guns in more
places is not part of the solution it's
the biggest part of the problem as a
nation we remain number one when it
comes to both our firearm homicide rate
and our firearm suicide rate and no
other country is even
close guns do not make legislators safer
or our constituents safer they simply
make more people dead
last year in this chamber we saw how
quickly an argument between legislators
could escalate into a physical
confrontation I have no idea if either
legislator was armed at the time but
firing a weapon in a crowded chamber
either intentionally in self-defense or
completely by accident comes with
tremendous risks were we lucky that time
I'm not sure but something I am sure of
is that I don't want to depend on luck
the next time the tempers flare or the
next time someone's firearm falls out of
a purse or falls out of a
holer Beyond concern for Public Safety
and our own individual rights this issue
raises a key question is the people's
house an appropriate or a necessary
place for legislators to carry guns or
other weapons or should it be a place
reserved for Goodwill healthy debates
and our best ideas for moving this state
forward so we can help all of our
constituents lead Better
Lives we don't allow weapons to be
carried into our courtrooms we don't
allow them to be carried into our
prisons and whether openly displayed or
concealed we should never allow them to
be carried into the people's house by
anyone other than the Troopers and the
Security Professionals trained to deal
with these situations folks please vote
Yes to support this amendment thank
you the motion before for floor
amendment to house rule
64 a roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
the motion before us is floor amend M to
house rule 64 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Roy for
a parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that the
people's house every right should be
observed not just some of them and if I
know that in the people's house we lead
by example we have freedom for our
citizens we passed constitutional carry
why would we strip ourselves the very
rights we fought to give our citizens
and finally Mrs speaker if I know that
we are never going to support a rule to
roll back that and if I know that the
people that want this would also
probably be happy pulling all of our gun
rights not just in here would I stop
them right now with
this J recognize represent of muse for a
parliamentary inor
Mr Speaker if I know that if we're all
about supporting tradition today then
would I press the green button and
support this amendment thank you very
much the motion before us is floor
amendment to house rule 64 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're opposed
you'll press a red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds how house will be in
order represent power
all members president had an opportunity
to
vote house will attain the state of the
vote 154 voting a 127 voting a the
amendment fails
representative Reed offers floor
amendment to house rule
100 the chair recognizes representative
Reed thank you Mr
Speaker uh this is one of two rule rules
amendments that simply codifies our
already existing best practices in this
one all it says is that if a chairman
institutes a time limit for speakers
that that chairman will evenly apply
that to the extent possible and in an
alternating fashion the vast majority of
chairs already do this this also allows
the chair to be able to give the prime
sponsor or whoever's introducing the
bill any experts anyone the chair
chooses extra time to speak they just
have to add a little note saying why
they're doing that what this is
preventing is the very rare but actually
existing examples of a few chairs that
have acted not in the best way in the
past where they would come up with a
three minute time limit for the people
who disagreed with them on a bill and
then magically didn't imply that time
limit to people who agreed with them on
the bill doesn't usually happen most
chairs actually do the right thing but
it has happened and we don't make rules
for the the good actors we make rules
for the Bad actors and so this just
codifies what we're already
doing motion before us is floor
amendment to house rule
100 a division has been requested
members take your
seats e
the motion before us is floor amendment
to house rule 100 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent Davis
all members present had an opportunity
to vote also will attend to stay to the
vote 177 voting aay 205 voting aay the
amendment
fails representative Reed offers floor
amendment to house rule
58 is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker this simply changes
our word for our morning invocation
before session which currently says
prayer to reflection reflection is more
inclusive of a broad range of beliefs
not just people who are secular um but
also there are a number of religions
that do not do what we call pray or has
as we Define speaking to a deity there
are there are non-theist religions like
Buddhism and this would allow those
religions to also be represented and
therefore we would be more
representative of the the state as a
whole representative Reed has requested
a division vote members take your seats
the motion before us a floor amendment
to house rule 58 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if your opposer to press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
jurus all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attain to
the state of the
vote 160 voting A 222 voting a the
amendment fails
representative Reed offers floor
amendment to house rule
44A
44A and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker So currently
we are required by our rules to offer
three only three days public notice
before a public hearing three days does
not allow people time to come and engage
in the people's business three days does
not allow people time to get off work it
doesn't allow people time to arrange
child care if you're working on bills
that have to do with issues that there
are National experts three days does not
allow people time to arrange for travel
to come and give the committee expert
testimony uh uh in this amendment I've
switched it to 10 days three days is the
Thursday for that calendar for the
follow for the hearings for the
following week by switching it to 10
days it's simply the calendar before
that now I understand push back on we
have a lot of bills we have a lot of
business we're always running against
deadlines we're always
behind but each one of us asked people
to put us here every single person
wanted to be a legislator every single
person who's a chair I presume wanted to
be chair and while it's inconvenient and
maybe even
uncomfortable I think that including the
people in their own business is more
important than our comfort because we
wanted to do this job for them in
addition if we bar access to these
hearings because that we are surprised
three-day notice what we're really doing
is handing over influence to the people
who get to be here in other words the
people who are paid to be here here the
lobbyists so I just want to make sure
that people have more access to their
own hearings their own business their
own government and I think good
governance is more important than our
inconvenience in
scheduling representative Reed has
requested a division members take your
seats e
clear the motion before us is floor
amendment to house rule 44A this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend to state of the
vote 73 voting a 308 voting a the
amendment
fails representative Andress moves floor
amendment to house rule
33 house rule
33 chair recognizes representative
Stevenson
Smith thank you Mr Speaker so this
change would make it so that after an
election when the speaker assigns people
to committees the first named House
member would call the first meeting of
your policy committee at which the
committee who may have never met each
other before will elect the chair and
vice
chair how's that going to work I first
of all if I want to be a committee chair
should I start campaigning for that job
in I don't know June guess who might be
on the committee or should I just raise
as much money as possible and blanket
letters out to anybody that might be on
the committee and then once we get there
I succeeded and the best campaigner wins
it's not always the best nonpartisan
administrator of the committee
so it's just not going to work I don't
know how the organizational meeting
would get scheduled I mean chairs do a
lot of work before you actually meet
they're going through the bills they are
arranging presentations and agencies to
come in and talk to you for your
organizational meeting and none of that
work will be able to happen until some
other meeting happens and they get
themselves elected so please vote down
this amendment chair recognize
representative Andrew
yes thank you Mr Speaker I'm going to
make this very short I firmly believe
that where there are 20 people on each
committee and where all
Representatives we should be
allowed to elect the chairman and the
vice chairman of our
committee and even though for this year
everybody's been appointed the same
ones may get elected if this bill
passes I don't expect it to
pass but I want to give people some
thought to
change that I believe we need in the
House of
Representatives we need to give
the whole body of
Representatives more
opportunity to vote for different things
that have always been the same in the
past I think we need to change them for
the future thank
you the motion before us is floor floor
amendment to house rule 33 are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I those oppose
Nay Nays have it Amendment
fails representative Reed moves floor
amendment to house rule 52 house rule 52
and I have nobody speaking I guess
so
I do you recognize representative
Reed thank you Mr
Speaker so those of you who are not
completely no new know that for for all
the history of the body up until this
last term it only required one person to
remove a bill from consent and that
worked really well there's one
historical example of one representative
long ago before I was ever elected that
did something but other than that it not
only worked well um it also was very
important because I think it was three
years ago a member from across the aisle
from me pulled by one person pulled off
a bill from consent explained to the
entire body how the bill actually
impacted County governments in a way
that no one had anticipated and that
bill was completely
uh the the recommendation was overturned
unanimously by the body so when we have
a thousand bills before us it's really
important to have everybody's eyes on
these bills because not all these bills
get read by every member not every
member has the same understanding of of
those issues so it's really important to
have the ability to pull things off of
consent calendar consent we understand
to mean consent of the entire body
because when we do a unanimous consent
speech spe it requires how many people
to object only one one person can object
and force a vote so for all of our
history of this entire chamber it's only
been one person that removed a bill from
consent until last term when it jumped
up to
10 so this amendment rule uh change is
simply saying maybe not 10 how about
three I think that's a fair number and I
hope you support that
the motion before us is floor amendment
to house rule
52 pres Reed has requested a division
members take your seats
the motion before us is FL amendment to
house rule 52 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 182 voting
a22 voting a the amendment fails
representative Reed offers floor
amendment to house
rules chair recognizer representative
beler thank you Mr Speaker I Rise
vehemently against this bill
not because I have any particular
problem with the sex designation of the
chairperson in that position in fact if
this had simply offered to add the word
chairwoman I'd have no problem pressing
green my problem is that when used
properly the word chair is a verb not a
noun it is not who you are it is what
you're doing it doesn't become a
position until you add man man or woman
to the end of it and I think that would
send a terrible message if we can't use
parts of speech right thank
you chair recognize rips in of
Reed thank you Mr
Speaker so first of all this isn't a
bill this is an amendment to
rules so we should use language properly
chair is a noun I see a few of them
right here also we frequently use the
word chair as a noun some words have
multiple meanings actually if you open a
dictionary whole pages of dozens of
meanings for one word so yes chair does
mean a chairperson chair person is a
long word I thought chair nice short
sweet would be a better gender neutral
term and this replicates the process
that OS currently goes through when you
ask them to draft a bill if they come
across gendered language currently in
law they will automatically fix that
language that's what they've been doing
for years so this simply applies that to
our rules which OS does not have
anything to do with chair is just a
short simple inclusive version and I
don't think that people's genitals have
anything to do with the position so I
don't think chair man or chair woman
will be in order and with that I
appreciate your
time the motion before us is floor
amendment to house roles sen Reed has
asked for a division this will be a
division vote members take your seat she
clear the motion before us is Flo
amendment to houseal rules this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent
bro see represent thank
you
Forman all members had an opportunity to
vote member needs to stay in the
seat the house will attend to to state
of the
vote under 75 voting a 208 voting a the
amendment
fails representative Maguire Stringham
offer floor amendment to house rule 47f
47f the chair recognizes Representative
Steven
Smith thank you Mr
Speaker this rule would change the
current practice where a committee chair
can wave referral of a bill to requiring
a vote of the
committee so here's the problem
we're signing bills right now committees
aren't necessarily meeting right
now the committee chair sees no this
bill doesn't belong here and we've
already had one request for this now
they can't do anything about it without
scheduling a meeting of the committee
which by the way has to be noticed in
the calendar because when you're dealing
with a quorum of the committee it's a
public
meeting there could be times where this
pushes you past a deadline just so the
committee can meet and go oh yeah that
doesn't belong here so um just it will
definitely take more time and the likely
result is they're just not going to be
able to wave the referral because they
can't get the committee together to meet
right away so please let the chairs have
this flexibility vote against the
rule J recognizer representative
Stringham
uh thank you uh Mr Speaker this is a
bipartisan uh floor Amendment uh
sponsored by one each from each party uh
the need for this amendment was
identified uh last uh session in
response to it what was an inadvertent
mistake and so let me let me uh tell you
the very specific circumstances and why
this is more specific uh than the
previous speaker L on under rule 47 a
bill is automatically assigned
uh as uh to a second committee when
Appropriations or other circumstances
are involved uh we review policy bills
in the first committee and understand
the finances would be reviewed in the
second committee the first committee's
done with their work uh by by
mid-February for a two committee Bill uh
the second committee chair may want to
passing the bill but doing so would send
the bill immediately to the Senate
without any financial review what's
oever uh this amendment will allow to be
passed over to the second committee but
only after a review and a vote of the
full committee there's been some
concerns expressed that this would the
slow the progress of a committee Bill a
sec a two committee Bill isn't expected
to arrive in the Senate until after
crossover day in mid April as we said
these bills would be coming out of the
first committee and voted on the floor
in February so we can afford the few
days time for one meeting notice to make
sure we get it right uh this avoids a
problem that occurred where Finance
review was waved off when there were
significant Appropriations consequences
last year and on one occasion we believe
that the past version of the bill uh had
been later amended making the
Appropriations much more
substantial uh the co-sponsor and I
agreed we would Advance this rule change
regardless of which party was in the
majority and uh I'm happy to do that uh
here here uh it is not a
partisan uh Amendment this is just a
good governance Amendment you know we're
here as volunteers we know we have a
major lift to balance the budget and
preserve essential services for granted
Staters whether by accident or design we
should make full use of the skills of
both sides of the aisles or at least
allowing them to weigh in before uh
forgoing the critical review of the
budget and implications of a
bill uh this structure of the amendment
still allows for a majority of vote of
the committee uh uh to wave Financial
committee review for example uh after a
vote so this bipartisan request does not
limit the ability of the majority party
to jump the line it just does so with
more protections against a mistake with
more transparency I think we can work
together build a better budget and a
stronger New Hampshire please uh join
this bipartisan amendment to do
everything we can to get this right
please vote for this bipartisan floor
Amendment and I would ask for a division
vote thank
you Senator stringam ask for a division
members take your seats this will be a
division vote
clear the motion before us is floor
amendment to house rule
47f this is a division vote chair
recognized Representative Steven Smith
for M
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that we're about to enter a challenging
schedule where we're going to process
800,000 bills in like 90 days which is
insane and if I trust our committee
chairman to do a good job managing that
workload and want them to have all the
tools available to keep us on time and
not coming here on days when we don't
need to be here then would I press the
red red
button chair recognize representative
Stringham for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh if I
know that bills are assigned to a second
committee for very sound reasons and if
I know the first committees frequently
defer discussion of Financial and other
matters knowing they will be discussed
later and if I know that we have time to
do a quick review without slowing down
the work of this chamber
and if I believe that 18 heads are
better than one would I now press the
green button to help avoid errors thank
you the motion before us is floor
amendment to house rule 47f this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppose
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent bber
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 186 voting a 193 voting a the
amendment
fails representative Reed office floor
amendment to house rule 100 is
recognized to
speak thank you Mr
Speaker this is also a rules amendment
that simply codifies what we already do
it says basically what we already do
that when a chair gets a Minority Report
and this is usually if it's an issue at
all an issue with minority reports the
chair receives the reports from the
committee on a bill if the chair thinks
that there needs to be changes usually
to The Minority Report that those
changes should be agreed to by the
author and this requires that it be
signed consent for those changes
um in the past not always most chairs do
it correctly but some chairs have edited
material in a Minority Report without
permission in addition it's happened on
occasion that chairs have kind of
pretended to not have received the
Minority Report resulting in The
Minority Report not even being in the
calendar whatsoever so this says that
the chair has to follow that and submit
it in a timely way if it's changed it
has to be agreed to by the author and if
the chair simply doesn't submit it even
though they received it then the report
would be printed in the calendar without
change that's all what we currently
do Reed has asked for a division members
take your seats
soon
clear the motion before us is floor
amendment to house rule 100 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds for
[Music]
all members president have an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 173 voting aay 208 voting a the
amendment
fails chair recognizes the clerk for a
motion Mr Speaker representative Carol
McGuire moves at the house vacate the
reference of House Bill 197 relative to
the payment by the state of a portion of
retirement system contributions of
political subdivision employers to the
committee on done executive departments
and administration and to refer it to
the committee on
finance are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I I suppose nay
the eyes have
it before we go any
further we ask everybody to remain in
your
seats we're done with the
Amendments we're going to have a very
important
briefing that is is going to be closed
so we're asking everybody to stay in
your seats thank
you chair recognizes a member from
Auburn representative Osborne for motion
to adjourn from the early
session I resolve that the house now
adjourned from the early session and The
Business of the late session be in order
at the present time and when the house
adjourns today it be to meet on Thursday
January 9th 2025 in joint convention for
the purpose
of hearing the report of The Joint
Committee appointed to compare and count
the votes for governor and executive
counsel for the inauguration of the
governor and for the taking of The Oath
by the executive
counsel are you ready for the question
all those who faor say I those oppose
nay the eyes have it the motion is
adopted uh the house will attend to
announcements chair recognizes
representative alisandra Murray
announ after
announcements thank you Mr Speaker um I
just wanted to invite you all to St
Paul's Church this Friday from 10: to 12
uh a couple Disability Advocates reached
out to me wanting to speak to folks
about the Medical Aid and dying and
explain from a disability perspective
why they don't support that legislation
um so I'll be hosting um a presentation
and a conversation with them at St
Paul's Church 10: to 12 this Friday free
lunch is provided um so hope to see you
there thank you chair recognizes the
clerk for announcement thank you Mr
Speaker a couple of quick announcements
one immediately following the recess
motion there will be a security briefing
in the chamber all members of the press
all members in the gall Gallery U need
to leave the chamber uh pursuant to part
two article 8 of the New Hampshire state
constitution following that there will
be a 1-hour uh break for lunch um at
which time the uh anti-harassment
training uh presented by the Department
of Justice will take place in the
chamber that should that training should
last an hour following that there will
be a democratic caucus in the chamber um
so please if you are a democratic member
stay uh couple of other quick
announcements if you are a committee
clerk you will receive email from me but
there will be a training next Wednesday
morning at 900 a.m. in room 30133 of the
legislative office building please be
there um there is a plastic uh dog box
container for treats and or toys or
something in the anti room um the it is
left over from the last session day when
uh items were uh donated whoever left
that there please retrieve it or it will
be recycled uh lastly uh for the
inauguration tomorrow um the session
will begin at 11:30 you should be here
and in your seats if you have heard
directly from me if you've been
displaced which you should have if you
indicated you wanted to be here um I
your seat is all set if you are in a
display seat and would like to come
please see me I you have the list down
here and I hope you have a great
weekend we're moving on to unanimous
unanimous consense the chair recognizes
representative Oregon
thank you very much Mr
Speaker
um I'll be uh I'll be brief Al the
course if somebody says they're brief
then they've already like said something
that's not necessary but anyway July 4th
2026 is the 250th anniversary of the
Declaration of Independence that's just
a little less than 18 months from today
that may seem like a long way away but
you know it's actually pretty soon it's
going to happen pretty soon three years
ago in three years ago I was a prime
sponsor of the bill which established
the American Revolution cester
Centennial committee
commission cester Centennial is a f
fancy way of saying 250th anniversary
this case a 250th anniversary of the
founding of our
democracy and I can only take a little
bit of credit for that I was just a
first name among several co-sponsors and
House State Federal had to do a lot of
work on our bill before was ready to go
over the wall to the so-called other
body but if I remember correctly it was
such a good bill the other body just uh
uh just rubber stamped what house state
federal uh did so thank you very much to
the past and future members of that
committee you know we're couple of years
too late but hey better late than never
so I just want to say let's do
everything we can during the upcoming
two years to make sure this Saturday
July 4th 2026 is the day we're
celebrating all holidays matter but that
one matters um even more than the others
so thank you very much Mr Speaker and
that's it chair recogize representative
Chris
schs thank you Mr
Speaker President James Earl Carter Jr
in no particular order the wonderful
things that um are being said about him
include the 39th president a man of
Peace Integrity compassion resilience
and a life filled with service to our
country in so many forms from Humble
background in Plains Georgia as a peanut
farmer with no electricity growing up
and in a town where whites were very
much the
minority these circumstances shaped his
entire
life you know he lived to be a hundred
years old and the oldest president
ever Naval Academy graduate and served
on the First Fleet of nuclear submarines
under Admiral Rick
over he appointed more people of color
to the to Judiciary positions than all
total presidents before him
combined Nobel Prize winner devout
Baptist and Sunday school teacher husand
to husband to rosand for about 80 years
and father to four grandparent to many
and a lovely extended family as well
cancer
survivor and then the thing that is said
about him most he defined what the post
presidency could be in the most
excellent
way when he established the Carter
Center he
expanded efforts to monitor elections
across the world expanding access to
democ democracy and learning how to have
Fair
elections he also focused on eliminating
diseases around the world and if you
don't know about his elimination of the
guinea worm and what that horrible um
parasite would do is an interesting
thing to
Google and it's quite an
accomplishment that I say he's a Nobel
Prize winner for his human rights
work and the thing that um
inspired me and probably many of you the
Camp David Accords we brought together
monum vean and onor Sadat in a
successful way and one of my professors
when I was in college he had served as
an interpreter and um assisted President
Carter in that he was my favorite
professor and I took every class of his
I could Dr Abdul aiz SED originally from
Syria
and then there's Habitat for Humanity I
mean the list of things that go on I
mean how many of us picked up a hammer
to help uh with hurricane relief for
building new homes in areas that uh
needed new housing probably be a good
idea to do that
here and I think the reason why I was
compelled to ask to give this talk is um
just the personal note of Cath TH Rogers
who is a colleague who passed away a
couple years ago worked for Jimmy Carter
and his presence in New Hampshire was
really interesting and at his at Kathy
Rogers funeral Senator Shaheen told
hilarious story about Kathy somehow
getting a a pig into the opponent's
office and somehow connecting that to
farm uh policy anyway I feel like Kathy
Rogers is with us here today to honor
him she probably would have written a
better speech than I'm than I'm giving
and when I listen to the speaker of the
US House and the Senate leader in DC and
the vice president they all three of
them said he was the first president
that they were aware of as a gen xer he
was the first President I was aware of
too as a first grader 6 years old in
1976 we got to vote with photos and we'd
Circle the one and I was so excited to
Circle Jimmy Carter's picture and cast
my vote that you know my school had I
think he won the
election
anyway I just will say regardless of
party there's so many things I could say
about him but I think you can agree that
you can see within him many things that
would Inspire any of us to be better
Servants of our public to do better as a
human being I think there are things
about his life that could Inspire
anybody and his funeral is tomorrow and
he will be having his homegoing ceremony
in PL uh Plains Georgia in the coming
days and it's with that in mind that I
honor him with your um
participation and Mr Speaker I hope we
can have just a moment of silence for
this wonderful man and for his life of
service uh to our country and around the
world everybody rise for a moment of
silence thank you Mr
Speaker will reme will members return
turn to your
seats not
yet representative Au Osborne moves at
the house stand in recess for the
purpose of introduction of bills vacate
motions and receiving messages are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppos nay the eyes
have it the motion is adopted the house
is in recess until Thursday January 9th
2025 at 11:30 a.m.